وكما تعلم، فقد دعونا إلى وقف
فوري لإطلاق النار وهو وقف طويل الأمد
للقتال، ولكن هذا
يعني أننا لن نغتنم
الفرصة في أي وقت
يتوقف فيه القتال للحصول على المزيد من المساعدات،
لذلك أنا  آمل أن ينجح هذا من أجل
الرهائن أولاً وعائلاتهم، ولكن
أيضًا لأنني أعتقد أنه سيمنحنا
فرصة للقيام بعملنا في غزة، لذا فقد
كنتم كما تعلمون على الخط الأمامي لهذا
منذ البداية ولكنكم  هل تعلم أيضًا
أنك مبعوث خاص للأمم المتحدة ومستشار للعديد من
القضايا العديدة في اليمن وسوريا، لقد كنت
في اليونيسف وكنت تفعل ذلك
لفترة طويلة كرئيس
لعمليات الإغاثة NOS، هل
سبق لك أن رأيت شيئًا كهذا ماذا كيف تفعل
أنت تقيم ما يحدث الآن فيما
يتعلق بالاحتياجات الإنسانية في
غزة، وهي أسوأ منطقة مسيحية على الإطلاق وأنا
لا أقول ذلك باستخفاف، أعني أنني بدأت
في العشرينات من عمري في التعامل مع شركة C Rouge
وأنت تتذكر مدى سوء ذلك الأمر في The
Killing Fields وهكذا  لكن
68% من القتلى في غزة هم من
النساء والأطفال، توقفوا عن إحصاء
أعداد الأطفال الذين قتلوا بعد أن تم
إحصاء أربعة آلاف ونصف، لا أحد يذهب إلى المدرسة في غزة،
لا أحد يعرف ما هو مستقبلهم،
أصبحت المستشفيات مكانًا للحرب لا
لا أعتقد أنني رأيت
شيئًا كهذا قبل أن تكتمل
المذبحة المطلقة لمارتن غريفيس، كما
تعلم، يقول الإسرائيليون إنه
تم ذبح 1200 من شعبهم في 7 أكتوبر،
وكما نعلم تم أخذ حوالي 240 رهينة
بما في ذلك الأطفال الرضع.  كبار السن والعجزة
الخ السلطات الفلسطينية تقول أن
أكثر من 12 ألف أه شخص قتلوا
في غزة نعتقد أنك قلت أن 68% منهم
نساء وأطفال يجب أن يكون هناك
مزيج من المدنيين وأنا أفترض
المقاتلين ولكن كيف يمكنك أه
تحليل الصد  من الإسرائيليين
وأحيانًا حتى الأمريكيين أننا
لا نستطيع حتى الوثوق بهذه الأرقام منذ متى وأنت
تعتمد على
أرقام وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية، وما مدى دقتها
على مر السنين، والآن
يتعين علينا أن نقول أنك تعرف إدارة حماس
أو السلطات  في رالا، هل يمكنك تفصيل كل
ذلك بالنسبة
لنا، نعم أونرا الذي كان موجودًا طوال
هذه العقود العديدة، كما تعلم،
تدير هذه المؤسسات لمساعدة
المؤسسات الأخرى على العمل، ونحن في
مكتبي نستخدم بالفعل أه
الإحصائيات المقدمة على سبيل المثال من
وزارة الصحة وغزة وأه قمنا
بتثليثهم على مر السنين
للتأكد من أننا نشعر بالثقة بهم
لذلك لدينا تاريخ طويل لا
نطرح هذه الأرقام دون تفكير أه
وأعتقد أن الناس يمكن أن يثقوا بنا بما فيه الكفاية
ليعرفوا  أنه عندما نقول هذه الأشياء فمن
المحتمل جدًا أن نكون قريبين من الحقيقة
وبصراحة مدى ذلك فإن الأرقام
فظيعة جدًا لدرجة أنها نوع من
التساؤل الأكاديمي عما إذا كان هناك بضعة آلاف
هنا أو هناك وحقيقة أن هناك
المزيد من الأطفال الذين قتلوا في هذا  صراع
أكثر من أي صراع آخر يمكن أن نفكر فيه على
الإطلاق، كما قال أميني العام،
لا داعي للقلق بشأن ما إذا كان
هناك 100 أكثر أو 100 أقل إلا إذا
كنت في المائة، عليك فقط أن
تدرك أن هذا أمر سيء للغاية  يبدو الأمر كذلك يا
مارتن غريفيث، مع كل خبرتك،
لماذا تعتقد أن الإسرائيليين، المتحدثين الرسميين،
والمسؤولين الحكوميين الذين يتحدثون
نيابة عنهم يركزون بشدة على
حقيقة أنه لا ينبغي لنا أن نصدق هذه
الأرقام هذه المرة، لم أر ذلك
من قبل  حسنًا، أنت
مألوف أكثر مني أنا مسيحي، لذا أعتقد أن هذا
مثير للاهتمام للغاية، يجب أن تقول ذلك،
أعتقد أن السبب في ذلك هو
أن السابع من أكتوبر كان
كابوسًا مروعًا للغاية، فأنا من بين هؤلاء
الأشخاص الذين شاهدوا المجموعة
مقاطع فيديو لما حدث في تلك الأيام
والصدمة التي
سببتها بشكل واضح ومفهوم للعديد من
العائلات في إسرائيل رقم اثنين
الأعداد
11,000 13,000 مهما كان الأمر في غزة
قتل أعداد النازحين أربعة من كل
خمسة أشخاص على قيد الحياة في غزة نزوح 1.6
مليون شخص لا  أقصد أنهم سيبقون لفترة أطول في منازلهم،
أعني بالطبع أنه يمكنك أن تفهم لماذا
أرادت إسرائيل تحدي هذه الأرقام
لأنها مروعة للغاية وقد
أدت إلى
رد فعل عالمي كهذا. غزة أزمة عالمية كما
تعلمون، إنها ليست مجرد أزمة بشأن غزة،
إنها أزمة  عن الإنسانية، إنها
أزمة تؤثر على السياسيين في جميع أنحاء
العالم، إنها أزمة تخرج
الناس إلى الشوارع بأعداد كبيرة،
إنها أزمة تدمر
إيماننا الذي بني على مدى عقود عديدة
بأن الحرب لا ينبغي أن تكون
الخيار الأول، وأنا مرعوب  لنرى أن
هذا غير صحيح في هذه الحالة، فقد
أصبحت الحرب خيار اليوم
والمعاناة الناجمة عنها
هائلة